Oh
I had this introduction of Professor
Jackson worked out for last town when he
was scheduled to speak and when he
couldn't come RJ prostrate Oh filled in
for him beautifully and he couldn't come
because uh Gina had given him another
baby and they were going to bring it
home from the hospital and he wouldn't
miss that I guess he thought Gina might
drop it and my introduction last time
was that I was going to use the occasion
to settle the dispute that Gina and I
have his Gina here she's going to come
sometime but her presence is here in a
way that I'm about to make known to you
because she and I haven't been arguing
for years what he looks like she claims
he looks like a hobo and I claimed that
he looks like Rasputin the mad monk or
else he looks like the great uncle of
Raymond's beyond
but I have to recite his resume and the
question of his appearance begins with
the first award this ever this man has
ever received which I'm now going to
show to you he was the calendar boy for
the big boy market in Modesto California
and now you can all thank Gina for this
and less this should ever be forgotten
there are about 200 copies of this
photograph back there for any of you who
want them to take because I think it
important for them to get around Justin
Jackson is a very unusual man he comes
from odesk OC calendar boy what does he
do medieval literature he knows old and
middle english he probably knows all the
literature we have from it nearly by
heart he is this kind of a teacher he
has broken down the parts of the
teaching art into its component parts
and he is beloved by all of the students
to whom he so consistently gives sees
I had the pleasure of a two-hour
conversation with him it probably wasn't
pleasurable to him but it was so much
fun to me because He pours forth how to
do it and he can stay exactly what he
wants them to be able to do they must
learn to analyze literature and that
less that means they must get inside it
and see what it means and why it means
that and how it expresses the meaning of
that and then they must having
understood that that is as they learn to
read that way they must be able to
present that in an organized and clear
and concise piece of writing and that is
such a difficult thing to learn how to
do and if you prospective students learn
how to do that thing you will be a
different person than anything else
could make you into be and one of the
few best people i have ever seen at the
teaching of how to do that thing is our
beloved justin jackson
thank you congratulations Jim much much
deserved you become responsible forever
for what you obtained some thoughts on
roses foxes and friendship president
Arne my wonderful beloved colleagues
students and guests I'm honored to have
been asked to speak to you today at
convocation now I say honored and not
delighted not because he's sitting to my
right to be perfectly honest I'm really
ill equipped to give a talk like this I
have not the eloquence of dr. burr sir
the wit of dr. Whalen the decency nor
the grace of dr. Wyatt Hayes nor the
majestic sonorous voice of dr. Connor
I like to think I'm as funny as dr. iron
but those sorts of jokes get you fired
if you're not the president of the
college the birth of my son Simeon got
me out of the last address so i thought
i was in the clear but obviously I was
wrong I've tried diligently all week to
get out of this I really I have my whole
family has been wiped out and in bed for
the past week with strep and in running
103 degree temperatures I had hoped to
be infected
my daughter's thought it rather strange
though entertaining that I kept licking
their hands and faces
mumbling give me those germs and dabbing
like cheeks with their used tissues
yesterday I actually offered dr. Sun
doll ten bucks to hit me with his car
but he declined indicating that he was
worried about putting a dent in his
precious I thought that was rather sweet
he's never called me his precious before
nevertheless I am here and really not
only am I honor to be here today i am
happy happy to be here with my
colleagues and friends of course but
especially happy to see you seniors I
have grown close to many of you and have
witnessed your intellectual and
spiritual maturation and consider myself
fortunate for having studied under you
when I was asked to give this address my
first question my first question to dr.
Blackstock was simple what are we
looking for in this sort of talk dr.
Blackstock suggested that I offer
something that would take us away from
the hustle and bustle of our daily
activities especially at this hectic
time of the year that perhaps I could
look to something uplifting but I
imagine that the most uplifting thing I
could offer would be simply to point out
the fact that we are here in a moment
carved out for us already from the
hustle and bustle a place where we find
the friends with whom we spend our time
and waste our time the professor than
the students from whom we all learned so
much so here we are again at the end of
the year saying goodbye to friends with
whom you've just become acquainted at
freshman convocation dr. aren't often
reminds parents of their bittersweet
moment what they've waited worked and
hoped for for their children this new
life at college this foray into
adulthood has finally come to pass these
parents have cultivated nourished their
children and now they must give them up
offer them to us to continue this
project these parents must now say
goodbye today many many of us here feel
the same way we have come to know you
and to know ourselves better because of
you and now you must leave us and this
makes me sad we humans are a funny lot
aren't we there's something in us that
can't help but to affirm and participate
in the goodness of life even when a
participation in that goodness
and that beauty will ultimately lead to
sadness I often like to tell my students
about my daughter Lydia and her first
exposure to death her goldfish died I
would like to say that it was a sad day
but Lydia didn't quite get death at that
point she slowly came to the realization
that her fish wasn't going to be
swimming any longer that she would no
longer have to feed him because he was
dead when we walked outside to give her
fish a proper burial she turned to me
and asked data if a fish dies does that
mean birds die we don't have a bird she
just likes Birds yes yes sweetheart
birds die do cats die I knew where this
was going yes sweetheart cats die even
Floyd this is our cat yes and if Floyd
eyes does that mean puck will die he's
our dog with one eye you can see the
clear hierarchy of pets here fish bird
cat dog Liddy's Lydia's my budding
little aristotelian
Matilda to data this is our dog with two
eyes yes sweetheart you're going to die
data yes sweetheart daddy will die and
if you die will mommy died and I thought
hey at least I rate higher than the docs
yes sweetheart mommy will die and will I
die data see how much fun parenthood is
yes sweetheart you will die I tried to
explain that though we die we don't
really die but this explanation didn't
really interest her Lydia look down at
the grass as we walk took a few more
steps look back and asked can I have
another fish and with this single
question the pronouncement of her desire
for the responsibility to feed a
goldfish to name it to watch it swim to
watch it die in to bury it with all of
this my three-year-old simultaneously
rejected the absurdity and
meaninglessness of death and suffering
and affirmed the beauty of God's
creation affirmed and accepted our
vocation indeed life itself a life of
responsibility and without
responsibility of vulnerability for a
brief moment a very brief moment she
stood at the crossroads of nihilism to
see humans is simply being done to death
that all is in fact vanity and she
rejected it and wished to accept her
role as a person who needs to be
responsible for others a person who
needs to feed a fish the title of my
talk a line taken from the book the
little prince you become responsible
forever for what you have tamed seemed
rather appropriate today
as I look out into the audience I see
only an affirmation of what it means to
be human I see students for whom we as
faculty are responsible students who
came to this College to have their minds
cultivated their souls tamed this is
really true when you enrolled at
Hillsdale College you asked to detained
you came to our classes to our office
hours and requested please tame me and
we obliged tapley to our guests here
today a bearded unkempt ogre ish looking
man declaring that we have tamed these
students must seem must seem hubristic
at best and coldly despotic at worst but
here is the secret so many of these
students and certainly all of my
colleagues have discovered in the act of
taming someone about whom we care we to
become tamed the octave taming implies
not domination not some sort of
condescending didacticism but an act of
responsibility of self giving a
vulnerability for both parties and as
much as we try to help shape the minds
and souls of our students so are our
minds and souls shaped by them I'm
willing to argue that there is an
intellectual and spiritual give-and-take
going on in office after office on this
campus on a daily basis a student comes
to the office of the professor with a
paper her thoughts on Aristotle and CS
Lewis perhaps even her deeply held
beliefs a paper which contains not
simply clever thoughts strung together
not simply footnotes to show she's read
the relevant literature but something of
the students of central being something
invisible to the eye but something more
real more palpable than the paper on
which the student has communicated her
thoughts she has learned in some way how
to think from us having been tamed or
perhaps still being tamed in our
we all she offers something back to us
when she hands us the paper not our
thoughts regurgitated but our thoughts
appropriated taken on by her own
experience her own thoughts and
communicated back to us through her own
words she offers us something outside of
ourselves back to us a gift perhaps she
even offers our very personhood back to
us she tames us for she has actually
been responsible for us all along this
is perhaps the very secret many of you
now must understand as you're about to
leave this campus to get a job to get
married and horror of Horrors to have
children all of this time when you
thought you lived under the thumb of
your parents as they tried to direct you
in your various endeavors be it by rules
or by finances they were trying to tame
your young spirit well you were right in
thinking this this is exactly what they
were trying to do they were taming you
directing you but here's what you may
not know you've always had the upper
hand you were never the servant in this
relationship you were always the master
you were being tamed but in doing so
your parents offered themselves as a
gift to you and now it's your turn you
are now the ones who must go out and do
the taming and yet always remain mindful
that the first gesture of taming the
first true act of love is vulnerability
the willingness to suffer a recognition
that you two will be tamed and this is
what it means to be human I hope
everyone will forgive me for this but
today I'm going to read from the little
prince it's a wonderful little
children's book and seems apropos for
today if you are interested in an
investigation of the ontology of love as
a phenomenological occurrence that
ruptures the horizon of haida garion
being
it opens up the infinitude of a
self-emptying she noetic hypostatic
instantiation of a fee andric existence
proper than this children's book is for
you but today i simply want to focus on
a scene when the little prince
encounters a fox and learns a little
something about his love for his rose
back on his home planet asteroid b 612 i
simply wish to read this to you and will
resist the urge perhaps for once in my
life to comment on this piece of
literature the little prince asked what
does that mean tame it is an act too
often neglected said the Fox it means to
establish ties to establish ties just
that said the Fox to me you are still
nothing more than a little boy who is
just like a hundred thousand other
little boys and I have no need of you
and you on your part have no need of me
to you I am nothing more than a fox like
a hundred thousand other foxes but if
you tame me then we shall need each
other to me you will be unique in all
the world to you I shall be unique in
all the world I am beginning to
understand said the little prince there
is a flower I think that she has tamed
me the fox gazed at the little prince
for a long time please tame me he said I
want to very much the little prince
replied but I have not much time I have
friends to discover and a great many
things to understand one only
understands the things that won tames
said the Fox men have no more time to
understand anything they buy things
already made at the shops but there is
no shop anywhere where one can buy
friendship and so men have no friends
anymore if you want a friend tame me so
the little prince tamed the Fox and when
the hour of his departure drew near ah
said the
I shall cry it is your own faults in the
little prince I never wished you any
sort of harm but you wanted me to tame
you yes that is so said the Fox but now
you are going to cry said the little
prince yes that is so said the Fox then
it has done you no good at all it has
done me good said the Fox because the
color of the wheat fields and then he
added go and look at the roses you will
understand now i can't i'm sorry i can't
read the low prince without showing you
about pictures he took so long to draw
them that yours is unique in all the
world then come back to say goodbye to
me and I will make you a present of a
secret the little prince went away to
look again at the roses you're not at
all like my Rose he said as yet you were
nothing no one has tamed you and you
have tamed to no one you were like my
Fox when I first knew him he was only a
fox like a hundred thousand other foxes
but I made him my friend and now he is
unique in all the world and the roses
were very much embarrassed you were
beautiful but you're empty he went on
one could not die for you to be sure an
ordinary passerby would think that my
Rose looked just like you the rose that
belongs to me but in herself alone she
is more important than all the hundreds
of you other roses because it is she
that I have watered because it is she
that I have put under the glass globe
because it is she that I have sheltered
behind the screen because it is for her
that I have killed the caterpillars
except the two or three that we saved to
become butterflies because it is she
that I have listened to when she
grumbled or boasted or even sometimes
when she said nothing because she is my
rose and he went back to meet the Fox
goodbye he said goodbye said the Fox and
now here is my secret a very simple
secret it is only with the heart that
one can see rightly what is essential is
invisible to the
what is essential is invisible to the
eye the little prince repeated so that
he would be sure to remember it is the
time you have wasted for your rows that
makes your rows so important it is the
time I have wasted for my Rose said the
little prince so that he would be sure
to remember men have forgotten this
truth said the Fox but you must not
forget it you become responsible forever
for what you have tamed you were
responsible for your rose I am
responsible for my rose the little
prince repeated so that he would be sure
to remember and so my dear seniors I
want to thank you for the time we have
wasted together it has been a pleasure